emmanuelle marie bonjour
bonjour merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation ce matin la confédération
paysanne qui appelle donc à la
mobilisation aujourd'hui notamment pour
dénoncer la méthanisation pour commencer
en quelques mots expliquez-nous de quoi
s'agit-il
alors on dénonce pas la méthanisation la
méthanisation en soit c'est une très
bonne chose il s'agit de produire de
l'énergie avec des déchets dans l'absolu
donc dénoncer la méthanisation ça
n'aurait pas de sens par contre la
manière dont elle est mise en place avec
des sommes et des sommes faramineuses de
l'argent public et l'industrialisation
de son de son fonctionnement ça oui on
le remet en cause je voulais juste vous
faire une petite parenthèse cette cette
mobilisation est pas en lien avec celle
que vous avez décrite en préambule à
bruxelles c'est bien c'est pas du tout
la même chose ce sont deux choses
différentes et on va en parler
d'ailleurs aussi
dans l'eau et du coup ces dérives que
vous craignez quelles sont elles
alors elles sont de plusieurs ordres
elles sont deux elles sont d'ordre socio
d'ordre environnementaux est d'ordre
économique
ce qui se passe aujourd'hui en fait
c'est que on permet à des paysans de et
des paysannes de développer de la
méthanisation pour pour compléter leurs
revenus ça veut dire ça veut dire qu'en
fait le leurs revenus ne sont pas assez
suffisant quand ils travaillent la terre
et ça c'est un vrai un vrai problème une
vraie question
la production la production d'énergie en
soit elle peut être nécessaire mais dans
un dans un monde qui continue à ne pas
vouloir économiser l'énergie et à passer
à une société plus sobre là par contre
de même ça n'a pas beaucoup de sens par
ailleurs cette production de
méthanisation peut engendrer des dégâts
environnementaux considérables
il s'agit de produire du méthane le
méthane est un gaz qui est quatre fois
plus dangereux que le co2 en matière de
réchauffement climatique
donc si on imagine des fuites alors pour
l'instant les installations sont neuf
donc des fuites a priori doit pas y en
avoir mais dans dix ans dans 15 ans dans
20 ans quand le cocan les le matériel
comment serait un peu plus obsolète
qu'est-ce qui se passera on n'en sait
rien
de même les digestats c'est à dire les
déchets propres de la delà de la
méthanisation qu'on utilise comme
fertilisants sont des fertilisants qui
peuvent se transformer très très vite
très très rapidement en nitrates les
nitrates qu'on peut retrouver très
facilement et rapidement dans l'eau à
tous toutes ces choses là qu'on maîtrise
très mal qu'on maîtrise très mal encore
et qu'on veut qu'on commençait à
produire en quantité industrielle font
que les risques sont énormes et c'est
pour ça que nous on demande un moratoire
vous parlez de d'environnement et de
respect de l'environnement c'est l'objet
en tout cas de ce sur quoi vont voter
les députés aujourd'hui à bruxelles au
fameux pacte vert que là aussi des
inquiétudes se dessine du côté des
agriculteurs parce que les rendements
seraient seraient impactés
alors le pacte vert de même nous on ce
n'est pas avant deux bouts contre le
pacte vert le principe du farm tôt fork
ça nous semble être une me semble être
une bonne une bonne voie elle est encore
elle est encore très timide mais de
vouloir s'insurger contre le contre la
baisse des rendements ou en fait les
gens qui manifestent actuellement à
bruxelles c'est des gens qui veulent pas
changer les choses et qu'ils veulent
qu'ils veulent continuer à produire de
la manière dont ils produisent avec des
intrants chimiques et de manière
intensive
leleu a priori le projet le projet du
pacte vert européen pourrait commencer à
mettre un terme enfin insuffler une voie
différente dans la production agricole
et de l'alimentation pour vous donc
c'est une bonne chose contrairement à
ceux qui manifestent alors
partir dans cette voie là oui c'est une
bonne chose maintenant le pacte vert il
le pacte vert il est très certainement
très critiquable mais c'est pas la
direction dans laquelle il va se passer
cette direction-là compliquera une
certitude quels sont les points qui
sache alors selon vous dans ce pacte
vert
alors ça c'est au ces au syndicat
majoritaire notamment en france qu'il
faut demander c'est pas c'est pas à moi
à ce qui ce qui fâche et ce qu'il
fallait surtout sexy lady va être
demandé de plus en plus devenir assez
coercitive aux adducteurs européen de
produire de manière
de manière différente c'est à dire
d'abord de moins en moins avec l'aide
des intrants chimiques mais il faut dire
que ça provoque ces normes enfin c'est
quelque part c'est un peu normal que ça
provoque une telle une telle levée de
boucliers parce qu'on a poussé des
agriculteurs depuis depuis des dizaines
d'années à produire de cette manière là
et il ya aujourd'hui une dépendance
tellement forte de la production
agricole avec de cette manière de
produire qui évidemment très compliqué
ou très difficile de passer à autre
chose merci beaucoup et emmanuelle marie
d'avoir accepté notre invitation ce
matin je le rappelle vous êtes
secrétaire de la confédération paysanne
[Musique]